ألا تكره ذلك عندما تضطر إلى الاتصال بالرقم
9-1-1 لأنك عالق في وضع مقلوب ،
فأنا عالق في هذا الاتجاه المعاكس مثل
تخفيف الضغط في الظهر ، شيء جيد
تمكنت كريستين فالز من استخدام ساعتها الذكية
للاتصال بالرقم 9-1  -1 وأعتقد أن
الشيء ذهب بعيدًا جدًا وأنا عالق
رأسًا على عقب ولا أستطيع أن أضع نفسي
رأساً على عقب
في صالة الألعاب الرياضية القوية في باريو
أوهايو مفتوح 24 ساعة الشخص الآخر الوحيد
الذي عرفته كان في صالة الألعاب الرياضية معها  في الثالثة صباحًا ،
كانت جيسون في غرفة أخرى ترفع الأثقال
ولم تستطع سماعها ، لقد كان
ضغطًا كبيرًا في رأسي ، وظلت تحاول
رفع نفسها بحرية ولكن لم يساعدها أي قدر من
الارتباك
على تعليقها هناك لمدة خمس أو ست دقائق
قبل أن تقرر  للاتصال بالرقم 9-1-1 ،
هذا أمر محرج للغاية ،
من المفترض أن تقوم الطاولة
المعكوسة بفك عمودك الفقري ،
لذا هل ستستخدم الطاولة المقلوبة
مرة أخرى
أه جيدًا ليس بدون صديق
وصل ضابط إلى صالة الألعاب الرياضية بعد دقائق قليلة من
استدعاء كريستين 9  -1-1
لما سار الشرطي في جايسون قال لي
ان الشرطي  جاءنا وقلنا أم
تلقينا مكالمة مفادها أن شخصًا ما عالق
معلقًا رأسًا على عقب ،
يا سيدي العزيز ، كاحلي
تحرقان الضابط ضحك ،
أسهل عملية إنقاذ على الإطلاق ، استمرت المحنة
لمدة 12 دقيقة تقريبًا
وكان يعاني من صداع بعد ذلك وشعر
ببعض الضبابية مثل الناس  كنت مثل
لماذا تنشر هذا الأمر
محرجًا للغاية ولكنني لا أحب ذلك ،
أعني في بعض الأحيان أنه يجب عليك فقط أن تضحك على
نفسك وتمضي قدمًا ولكن لا
مزيد من التمرين مثل هؤلاء الرجال ينامون ، نعم ،
يبدو نوعًا ما مثل جني الخفافيش.
نيويورك